post means and your content might get
flagged stop posting memes and your
account will remain safe at least for a
while but think about posting your
nameless videos many years from now and
ask yourself would you be willing to
trade all those days for just one chance
one chance to come back here and tell
them that they may copyright strike our
cows but they will never kill our babes
[Music]
[Applause]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that quite honestly might not
be able to air in Europe anymore that's
not an opening joke or an exaggeration
either
do you watch gamers or film criticism
channels have you ever laughed at a meme
a spongebob Santos or otherwise do you
have a Twitter or tumblr account have
you ever used anything from immature
jiffy or gif II depending on how you
pronounce it are you one of those people
who long for the old days of YouTube
when the big media companies weren't on
the platform I am sure between all of
those questions I am talking to a huge
chunk of you and if I am then pay very
close attention to today's episode
because a huge percent of the content
that you currently watch and share
online is on the chopping block
including this show and game theory and
GT Live and if there's any hope of
saving them well we've gotta act now so
if this is such a big deal then why is
no one talking about this supposedly
mning threat to all our online content
well I mean the name alone is the
directive on copyright in the digital
single market which grew boy if that
doesn't get you hyped well then you
don't even policy make bro in short it's
kind of complicated
my kind of complicated I mean really
complicated but you know me I eat
complicated topics for breakfast and
then spit them back at you in a
simplified more digestible way just like
a mama bird puking up little worm
nuggets and knowledge so let's get down
to it before this show goes the way of
spider-man on Titan Q the Thanos snap
transition since it might be one of the
last times we can use it I'm not feeling
so good Internet
you may have heard the words article 13
tossed around on and off throughout this
year if you follow me on Twitter you may
have seen me trying to sound the alarms
about this supposed meme ban a piece of
legislation that according to Facebook
quote could have serious unintended
consequences for an open and creative
Internet and according to YouTube CEO
poses a threat to creators livelihoods
and all of our ability to upload videos
to share our voices with the world but
then what is this thing that everyone is
so worried about well let me explain
right now
all websites and I mean all websites
including big ones like YouTube tumblr
Facebook Instagram snapchat reddit
Twitter they all rely on two key legal
principles to operate fair use and safe
harbor fair use is one that probably all
of you watching are familiar with at
this point since everyone on YouTube
claims that their video is protected by
it fair use is very very easy to
understand I'm Alex from I hate
everything and where's the fair use so
we will be the first client of this
account that will be known as the fair
use protection account also known as foo
but what is it exactly well it allows
for the use of copyrighted materials
without the permission of the original
copyright holder you may have seen some
video creators specifically go out of
their way to state that their use of
clips is for educational purposes now
it's all you've just learned in this
video that I've made for educational
purposes that's because educational use
along with criticism and review
commentary news reporting and research
are all things that are explicitly
allowed by United States fair use
doctrine it's how I'm able to show
gravity falls clips like this one and
cut out some characters like this one
when crafting theories about how the
show isn't over because the show isn't
over it shouldn't be over please don't
tell me it's over I refuse to believe
that it's over please bring back gravity
falls or how cinemasins can show clips
from a movie to send them or how honest
trailers can show clips from a movie -
honestly trailer them it's how we're
able to edit together Spongebob
Squarepants with the super smash
brothers world of light trailer to have
Squidward suddenly getting vaporized mid
bath or how Thanos can snap his fingers
to dust away the emoji movie thank you
for that by the way but what if
something doesn't fall under fair use
like if I just straight up re-upload a
chunk a Harry Potter well that's where
safe harbor come
you see according to the United States
Digital Millennium Copyright Act or DMCA
media companies can issue takedown
notices to website owners requesting the
removal of infringing content on their
site when someone uploads a 24 hour
livestream of FAMILY GUY to YouTube
YouTube isn't actually responsible for
committing that copyright violation
they're only responsible for removing it
that is the principle of safe harbor
that YouTube here is just an
intermediary it's not at fault for
someone misusing the system and
uploading illegal stuff as long as it
gets taken down and as such they're
shielded from copyright liability
that's why creators get copyright
strikes and not YouTube and just know
that when I say YouTube I really also
mean SoundCloud imager Facebook Twitter
Tumblr reddit pretty much any site that
allows users to upload content now
there's one problem that you might have
noticed with what I just described that
all of these laws are in the United
States the United States and fair use
doctrine the United States Digital
Millennium Copyright Act Europe has some
very different policies policies that
the article 13 mean ban threatens to
make even stricter you see in Europe
it's not called fair use
it's called permitted use now that at
first might seem like an insignificant
word change but just the name permitted
use actually speaks to how the European
doctrine differs from the US think about
what the word permit means it means that
you need permission to do something for
example you're not allowed to park
somewhere without a permit from the city
home improvements require a construction
permit from the government basically if
you're not allowed to do this unless we
say that you're allowed to and the same
applies to copyrighted works you're not
allowed to use them except we're
explicitly and expressly permitted to do
so and I think you can start to see
where the system might fall apart so
where are you permitted to use this
stuff well as stated before the US fair
use doctrine specifies that for purposes
such as criticism comment news reporting
teaching scholarship or research the use
of a copyrighted work is considered fair
however an important fact here is that
the list is in its
in other words the us fair use doctrine
is written in a way that basically says
lots of things can qualify as fair use
here are some examples this in turn
allows the law to remain flexible and
include new forms of media that have
arisen since it was written like memes
or vlogs which didn't exist back when US
copyright law was first being drafted by
contrast the European permitted use
policy takes the completely opposite
approach according to the EU is
copyright in the information society
directive of 2001 used for parody
quotation private copying or class
reviews are permitted at first that
seems pretty similar to u.s. doctrine
but then you realize that's it that is
the whole list anything that is not on
that list is automatically not allowed
under US law you could take something
like this scene hi how are you and remix
it to do something like this are you
quality meme 10 out of 10 clap clap and
US lawyers would say well this might
technically not be a criticism or
commentary but it's not like this person
is trying to take anyone else's work and
pass it off as their own fair use
European Union doctrine as it's written
says is it for class room is it a
quotation is it parody well then no
permit for you
oh and that last one about parody might
be a bit confusing but the legal
definition of parody is actually very
strict the best example is something
like a parody song in order to
officially qualify the new parody
version of the song needs to have lyrics
that directly make fun of the original
work so it's a very limited narrow
definition in short Europe's copyright
doctrine just tends to be a lot stricter
but article 13 is what threatens to make
a bad problem even worse because now
it's actively targeting the idea of safe
harbor it directly states that quote
online content sharing service providers
ie sites like YouTube tumblr reddit
whatever and rights holders the movie
studios music labels etc shall cooperate
in good faith in order to ensure that
unauthorized protected works or other
subject matter are not available on
their services so basically all these
sites need to work to ensure that
copyrighted stuff isn't uploaded
be that big of a deal right YouTube has
Content ID which protects against
wrongful uploads sometimes a bit too
aggressively but certainly enough to
ensure that I can't find full episodes
of Phineas and Ferb on here without
paying it should be cover and meanwhile
sites like dailymotion where you can
find literally all sorts of illegal
uploads on will be held accountable and
need to clean up their act
it all sounds reasonable right but
here's the trouble you see an earlier
version of article 13 mentioned quote
proportionate content recognition
technologies which sounds like what
YouTube already has in place automatic
detection of recognized content upon
upload and if that was actually what was
written well then things would be fine I
wouldn't be making this episode but this
didn't make it into the version that
paths
the people behind article 13 which is
mostly the music industry because quite
frankly the music industry tries to kill
anything that defines threatening wants
to keep the language vague because then
they can demand basically anything they
want and say well the law requires you
to cooperate in all good faith with us
what does good faith mean it's unclear
it's poorly defined and that's the
problem what they're demanding is that
nothing that has the potential to be
infringing be uploaded onto these
websites caching it via Content ID once
it's on the system is it good enough
they want to stop it before it even gets
uploaded so what does that translate to
well it has the potential to mean the
end of all user-generated content the
stuff that we all make I mean think
about it who loses in this situation not
the movie studios are the big media
companies they're all permitted to use
their own rights not the music industry
they just own the songs it's us all of
us we all lose it's the people on
YouTube and tumblr and tick tock and
Twitter and whatever we lose in a
conversation I personally had with
YouTube CEO Susan Wojcicki about article
13 she made it very clear if this ends
up going through with the current legal
language YouTube will have to treat
Europe like a bubble videos uploaded
outside of Europe won't be able to go in
and in Europe the only people who will
really be permitted to upload will end
up being the big companies if you need
even more proof she even wrote about it
quote if implemented as proposed article
13 threatens hundreds of thousands of
jobs European creators
mrs. artists and everyone they employ
the proposal could force platforms like
YouTube to allow only content from a
small number of large companies it would
be too risky for platforms to host
content from smaller original content
creators because the platforms would now
be directly liable for that content end
quote
the safe harbor shield that was
protecting YouTube from copyright
strikes may dissolve and because their
butts are on the line for all copyright
strikes now the only people YouTube can
allow to upload are the people they are
certain owns the IP rights the big
companies and all other sites would have
to follow suit and it is expensive and
difficult to make an appropriate Content
ID system even worse it could empower
media companies to make more erroneous
copyright claims such as the case where
Sony Music Entertainment went after
people posting classical music composed
by Bach what's more we usually think
about copyright protection as it applies
to movies and music but simple images
are covered by copyright as well every
painting every drawing every logo that's
posted to the Internet is copyrighted
material every tattoo that's not an
exaggeration tattoos are actually owned
by the artist who made them and of
course each and every meme
now I know what a lot of you are
thinking boy that sucks for people over
in Britain wait they're not part of the
EU hold up would Britain be affected by
article 13 sucks for people over in
Britain France and Spain but why should
I care well you might not be European
but the sites you use operating
countries that are part of the EU and
when different countries have different
laws companies usually cater to the
least common denominator
rather than having different policies
for users in different countries
companies will just usually target the
strictest set of rules and comply with
those then apply that set of rules to
everybody for a recent example of this
earlier this year you probably got a
flood of emails from Facebook Google
Reddit and pretty much every website
Under the Sun notifying you hey we've
updated our privacy policy click that
you accept it well the fact that you got
all these emails around the same time
was it a coincidence all of these
companies were updating their privacy
policy to comply with gdpr the general
data protection regulation passed in May
by you guessed it the European Union
these sorts of privacy and copyright
changes affect all users not just those
based in the EU and trust me once media
companies realize that they can take us
down in one part of the globe I
guarantee they'll be knocking down the
door trying to make it happen in more
corners of the earth so European or not
the EU copyright directive is something
that should matter to you threatening
your means your online shows and most
importantly the literally hundreds of
thousands of people who make their
living working online me the whole
theorist every youtuber that you want so
what can you do at this point well there
are three things first and most
importantly spread the word people
aren't talking about this because it's a
complicated issue but start raising
awareness about the dangers of article
13 share this video with your favorite
online creators and not because I'm like
give me a lot of views though in this
case I absolutely want this video to get
a lot of views well because I think I
did a pretty decent job of explaining
the issue in a clear way that wasn't
super boring basically we need people to
understand why this matters and then
number two make your own content start
tweeting about article 13 with the
hashtag Saviour internet make videos
raise awareness and finally number three
if you're in Europe talked to your MEP s
find out whether they supported article
13 and why convince them in a clear and
reason and logical way that article 13
as it's currently written will cause
significant harm to the European
Internet we need any piece to understand
what's really going on here and think
through the consequences of the language
of the law no one here is disagreeing
that the rights of copyright holders
should be infringed upon that's not the
issue the issue is that the language of
the law is too vague and as it's
currently written it opens the door for
media companies to abuse this
legislation and you have to do these
three things right away right now
because here's the thing this bad policy
isn't something hypothetical that could
happen it is something that has already
happened it has passed multiple times
and it is currently in the final stages
of boating it's a real thing they're
just solidifying the language now
if nothing is done to change that
language it could be finalized and
implemented in its current form before
the end of this year and it is this is a
preview of the show that you might just
end up seeing every week and that's no
Theory that's a fact
save your Internet guys help me save my
job this is a battle that really matters
and hey if you want to enjoy another
mean video well I'm still currently able
to air them click the box to the left to
watch more me me goodness as I calculate
the length of the single longest meme
ever created in history the length of
this thing is gonna shock you and
finally make sure you subscribe we have
some amazing theories coming up before
the end of the year and guardians of the
galaxy on the deadliest Disney movie on
some classic animated series spiderman
anime it's gonna be a good end of the
year so make sure they have a slightly
better chance of seeing it up here on
your homepage by smashing that subscribe
button and do me the favor ring the bell
that way you're guaranteed to get
notifications now go talk about article
13 save your Internet save my job all of
us over here on the theorist team are
hoping you're able to do it